just in case you're curious I
deliberately um I deliver they skipped
over this when I was talking about this
because you don't need to worry about
balloon poets are the kinds of questions
you have to it's that but for you guys
who are actually interested in the idea
of a balloon payment is if you see this
I know if you can make that out the
balloon payment I actually don't know
yet you don't find this out short why
it's called a blue pen but here's the
idea
oh no it's something else
here's the idea the deposit is a big sum
of money at the beginning that's how you
an initial write the balloon payment is
a big sign buddy and the end in fact it
takes the place off see how this 48
monthly payments okay you can nominate a
final balloon payment which will be in
place on the 48 payment and it's bigger
I'll show you what IV this balloon made
here we can say look I'll pay for 15% of
the whole soul just like $2,000 still
it'll come up in a second right I'm
gonna make that my very last payment
okay so just like the deposit right the
bigger the balloon payment the less all
the other repayments will have to be so
now if I update this estimate what's
gonna happen okay so you can see no ball
one my repayments all of my repayments
have reduced this wall that was so no
design before right yeah thank you
now I don't have 48 minutes just call 47
the very last one yeah me up the final
balloon payment is gonna be 5 grand
right so you see it's kind of like the
deposit too big chunk of money but it's
at the end rather than beginning well if
you've got access to it at the sides
much better okay it'll save you money in
the long run because I'll charge you
less interest but you know frankly the
reason why we get loads is because we
usually don't have access to that much
money or we need it for other stuff like
paying for groceries in Trenton you get
the idea okay so anyway you can go to
Twitter convey or wherever and you can
play with that
in fact I encourage you to do that
yeah down to 600 pay well I think the
best well you could make the term longer
right you go five years so you're paying
over a longer period of time and each
individual payment will be smaller how
much more they go so you can I'll let
you screw notes all these numbers here I
actually created a look at how to play
all right no no we've spent enough time
on tell you look on today you I think
all right um all this exercise 142 - I
can't say that I was I wouldn't be
surprised if they're very confident than
you pay off okay I'd like you guys to do
the odd questions but I'll just give you
a couple of examples I'll do some even
once we see you can see how to approach
it
okay have a look at number 2 for me it
says find the total cost of a car sorry
it's number 2 there's a large price of
15 grand
okay so if you like that's your
recommended retail right 15 read 142 but
it's sold on terms off now watch what's
going on here right you can either pay
down or you can pay $425 per month for
how long
four years it's right there at the end
now what question are they asking us
they're giving us all this information
what's the actual question read the
question carefully what question are
they actually asked us what I do with
all these numbers find the total cost
very good okay
now total cost means 142 it's a this
thing here right in fact this
recommended retail price is actually you
don't actually need in time it's a red
herring it's a it's a false clue you
don't actually include it in your
calculations all you do is this part
right the total cost it's pretty simple
actually you say take that about 425 now
how many months are there in a year
twelve months so every month you pants
that's twelve months there this is how
much you paid after one year so to get
four years worth what I do now multiply
by four in fact this is always the same
scenario but here 48 months right sure
because I added on another year River
yeah okay
so he going yeah
wait really yeah what'd you get oh you
said yeah I just need okay now it wasn't
that it's still a lot of money how much
of we on how much of extra we had to pay
versus the original price it's your five
thousand that's like an extra that's
like an extra intersection third it's
that same kind of 30 33 percent sort of
number that we saw before this is
standard for ones like this